a research firm caught up in the Russia
election probe now accuses Republicans
of working to mislead the public fusion
GPS Commission the so-called steel
dossier unverified intelligence on
president Trump's Russian ties using
money from a conservative website and
Hillary Clinton's presidential campaign
in this morning's New York Times to
effusions GPS founders claim the
president's allies in Congress are
running a fake inquiry they say the GOP
quote sought to tarnish our firm to
punish us for highlighting his links to
Russia they want Congress to quote
release transcripts of our firms
testimonies so that the American people
can learn the truth about our work CBS
News contributor ed O'Keefe is a
congressional reporter for The
Washington Post good morning good
morning
okay first remind everybody what fusion
GPS is and they're involved they're
basically former journalists turned
investigators who got hired during the
presidential campaign first by a
conservative news outlet then by the
Hillary Clinton campaign to look into
Donald Trump interesting yes sir the
suggestion had been by Republicans and
the president that's something that the
Democrats some opposition research is
what led to this idea of collusion
they're saying that's not true exactly
and what they're saying too is that you
know if anything the work they were
doing may have verified some things the
FBI was looking into and sparked the
whole thing but not necessarily the
collusion and that that dossier the
so-called dossier of the dirt and things
the gossip that he may or may not have
been doing when he was visiting Russia
four years ago was not the basis what
are they suggesting that the Republicans
are not looking into well the
president's business dealings basically
and and some other aspects of the
potential Russian attempts to influence
the election they're asking the
congressional committees they've talked
to to release their full transcripts and
say look once you do you're gonna
realize that there's a lot more here and
that in some cases these committees are
avoiding certain subject we have
multiple investigations going on is
there any sense that they can conclude
by in a bipartisan fashion well the one
that's doing the best at that is the one
being led by the Senate Intelligence
Committee Richard Burr the Republican
chairman from North Carolina and Mark
Warner from Virginia it's seen as the
most robust by many the most credible
congressional investigation but remember
all that one is looking into is the
scope of Russian potential Russian
interference or collusion or whatever
else in an attempt to sort of educate
the public in Congress about what may
have been done what could be done in the
future what needs to be done to avoid it
so it'll be interesting but it's not
necessarily going to be something that
leads to other political retribution
Congress has just a few things on their
plate as they try to get something done
this year January 19th and March 5th are
two big deadline dates why they're
connected to each other January 19th is
the next time we may or may not have a
shutdown getting old and kind of tired
to talk about this but that's the next
spending deadline and part of those
negotiations involve whether or not or
how to resolve the issue of dacha that
program that protects about seven
hundred thousand immigrants who were
brought here as children if it isn't
resolved by then the date to watch is
March 5th that's the current deadline
for the program the president set the
deadline in September telling Congress
you'll figure this out bring it to me
and we'll we'll cut a deal everyone
seems to want to resolve the daca issue
there give them permanent status or
figure out some other solution the
question is what's the compromise with
that even the president has said I don't
want to be the guy that is responsible
for deporting so many people but you
know the negotiation will be either do
you put up more money for a border wall
do you make changes to chain migration
or something else and nobody wants to
put that on the table because the moment
that ends up there it becomes the center
of debate and could lead to a lot of
different consequences when something
may also influence the President's
agenda in the future is the Republican
makeup of the Senate now that we know
that Orrin Hatch is retiring Mitt Romney
wants to run for a seat if Mitt Romney
runs will he likely win will he face
other opposition he's got a you'd have
at least one Republican primary
challenger and a Democrat who isn't
polling well right now so you know it's
only what January 3rd long year ahead
it could happen safe to say Mitt Romney
won't be a rubber stamp for president
right at all and and what it could
potentially create really is another
poll right there in the Senate of the
sort of never Trump or establishment
Republican movement that okay thank you
very much as always yes